MEANWHILE, MORE PEOPLE ARE
LINING UP AT FOOD BANKS WHICH
CAN’T KEEP UP WITH DEMAND.
DAVE, GOOD MORNING AND THANKS SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
SO MANY DIFFERENT ANGLES, AND
YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE CROPS
ANGLE, THE PROTISTS ANGLE.
HOW HAS THIS PANDEMIC AFFECTED
OUR FOOD SUPPLY?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, SANDRA.
IT’S BEEN VERY DIFFICULT.
WE HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY A VERY
EFFICIENT AND VERY SAFE FOOD
SUPPLY STRUCTURE AND THOSE
SUPPLY CHAINS HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED OVER THE YEARS.
WHEN THE SHUTDOWN HAPPENED IT
LITERALLY BLEW THEM UP.
WE’VE BEEN TRYING TO CONTINUE
FOOD OUTLETS, BUT THE LOSS OF
THE RESTAURANT SECTOR REALLY
THREW A GRENADE INTO THE MIDDLE
OF OUR FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN.
>> Sandra: SO WESTERN GROWERS
SUPPLIES MORE THAN HALF OF THE
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES IN THE
UNITED STATES.
YOUR FARMERS ARE BASED IN
CALIFORNIA, ARIZONA, NEW MEXICO
AND COLORADO?
SO GIVE US AN EXAMPLE OF HOW YOU
HAVE HAD TO JUST SAY SOME OF
THAT FOOD TO GO TO WASTE.
YOU ESSENTIALLY DON’T HAVE AN
END DESTINATION FOR IT?
>> LAST WEEK I WAS IN THE DESERT
AREA OF CALIFORNIA, ONE OF MY
MEMBERS PLOWED 350 ACRES OF VERY
HIGH QUALITY ROAMING LEAD US
BACK INTO THE GROUND.
THERE WAS NOTHING LIKE NO PLACE
TO PUT THAT PRODUCT.
WE’VE DOUBLED OUR DONATION TO
FOOD BANKS AND THERE IS STILL SO
MUCH FRESH PRODUCE WHICH OF
COURSE IS HIGHLY PERISHABLE AND
DOESN’T HAVE A MARKET BECAUSE OF
THE LOSS OF THE MARKET IN THE
FOOD SERVICE SECTOR, THE FARMERS
HAVE NO CHOICE.
THEY SPEND ABOUT HALF OF THE
TOTAL DOLLAR HARVESTING THE
CROP.
IF THERE IS NO PLACE TO SELL